hello youtube we're going to watch cobra
guy abstook you lose
thank you to everyone who's been
watching our reactions
hey subscribe click that notification
bell to get notified when our
next cobra reaction is up hit that like
button while you're at it
also major most sincere thank you to
everyone who has been following us over
at our patreon page
we're all checking out all the shows we
have to offer over there including the
full length ratchet watch along as we
sync up with the timecode for
cobra kai we have a bunch with reaction
highlights and watch longs over there
your support has been amazing
and really has been making a lot of this
well worth it so thank you guys so much
let's get on to this awesome ass show
[Music]
back to the dojo back to the streets
[Music]
panic at the dojo
what are you doing you didn't even fight
back i just went home and cried to mommy
is this a vision maybe
this is a real fight what the hell's
happening
did she not bring claws this time
oh
rock man did you see that yeah
now let's finish it wow
are you [ __ ] me
oh i was halfway there halfway there
because i was like
so something like this doesn't feel real
yeah
[Laughter]
oh
that falling cannot be good for his
spine
you have back surgery for your spine so
i get why it's so that means you already
feel it so much
he caught it
but maybe donate those to someone who
needs all right what about
johnny lawrence karate or strike hard
karate are they
working on starting up a new school come
on sen sam trying to help us think of
names for our new yo-yo
how long does it take for facebook
messages to get delivered
ali lives in colorado so probably a
while right that's instantaneous
we need something that tells everyone
we're the most badass dojo in the valley
how about that
sucks that cobra guy's such a badass
name what if we just keep that we spell
our cobra with a k
they can call us triple k oh
the cool kids club it's my first day
back at school today
hmm i could do some recruiting this is
going back to school why don't you have
a seat
i brewed up some of that tea that i
brought back from okinawa
ceremony you guys are being weird it's
another dream
this whole episode is just saying i'm
running a hill house
with everything you're going through at
school with those bullies we want to
make sure you know how to defend
yourself
so what are you saying double up on the
karate your dad's gonna reopen miakido
oh two percent on board no
oh sam
all i got from that was miyagi does
coming back i'm not doing karate anymore
okay i'm a pacifist you play hooky today
you know you go
work your miyagi magic
hey kitty
oh oh hawk's going to get pissed
they're totally giving him credit he's
cobra
what's up we're going to do cobra kai
he's crushing it right now uh i've
actually been meaning to talk to you
about that
uh-oh he's not gonna learn that
conversation
proximal radius fracture it smells i put
a lemon rind down there to mitigate that
and the invitation for you to sign it
still stands hard pass used to be a
thorn in my tits you were getting me
in science now you can't even do that
because you're
defective oh you are horrible
beat her up shall we start paperwork uh
who needs paperwork i'll take it and
i'll need to run your credit
i prefer if you didn't what do you say
we just skip all that crap make a good
old-fashioned handshake deal
like men
where's the juice bar where's the steam
room there was a vending machine down
the hall
but some homeless guy crapped in this is
la pal
you want a roof or four walls it's gonna
cost you
ain't that the truth this place is
this isn't so bad is it guess if he's
going to school they're going to wake up
on the coast of china
that's right with the secrets of
miyagidou
all right get your shoulder back bend
your elbows
let it fly
there you go where can you go fishing in
l.a
oh the some of the public lakes might
have like permits or something let's put
this episode on pause
let's find out google it let's go let's
just leave and go fish
you remember the last time we were out
here together that was the day we taught
you how to balance on the bow of the
boat want to give it another shot for
old time's sake
what do you say i knew it
secretly trying to teach her karate i
froze okay i watched dimitri get his arm
broken
i couldn't do anything and now i'm
having all these panic attacks and
and i don't know if i'm ever gonna be
able to defend myself i've been there
on a much smaller scale
oh buddy
he's got a cobra kai shirt didn't you
thought i was gonna knock down your tray
oh yeah i'm better than that here we go
oh you want me to sign you cass i'll say
no more what's he gonna break it again
write it on his face where am i supposed
to sit at the rejects table
over there the real rejects hey that's
our table
that's not what our sensei taught us
he's not my sensei anymore he betrayed
us
but this isn't you talking it's crazy
he's got in your head
you can change that if you leave cover
kind to insensei lawrence's new dojo
isn't your dojo
hey guys oh [ __ ] heading around with a
thick in his hand
oh conscience growing
funniest thing john said all reactions
it's my work for the month why don't you
walk me through what happened
hawk wanted to have warm beer
first time seeing her since i felt like
it would all happen again
my brain could feel it starting into my
body just
stuck i must have been terrified
dimitri got hurt and i couldn't do
anything to stop it
i'm scared dad
i've never felt so low no matter what
you're feeling right now it's nothing to
be ashamed of
you're up for a pit stop on the way home
hey what's up moose
what this dude's gonna cause some
trouble huh you know you just know he is
isn't he
oh damn there's no convincing them to
leave
wait here uh oh uh oh
he's gonna get into the fight at school
she's gonna
don't hit them
i screwed up i'm sorry i took the easy
way out
i gave up
ah couldn't look myself in the eye let
alone face all of you you bailed on us
long before that fight happened you got
soft
and we paid the price you listen up when
you came into my dojo you were softer
than a baby's ass
yeah i made you what you are
yeah so if you want to keep whining
about the past like a bunch of pussy's
fine we could play that game
don't say i didn't warn you when your
life ends up in the [ __ ] is this working
i can't tell this
story it's at least planting the seed
haven hurst magnolia mara4 i know those
streets
we can go train you better be there
[Laughter]
i think i think it's going to work and
by the way guys fun fact
haven hearst and magnolia actually don't
intersect with each other
it's great dad but still haven't told me
why we're here we're gonna solve your
problems with basketball
this is where i almost lost to fear
oh it's already
luckily i had mr miyagi there to help me
get my focus
i finished the fight and i won fight the
fight yeah
i still live with the fears i just tried
and not better ever win
sam you're the only one who could get up
when you're down no one else
i will be there always to help you
just like mr miyagi was there for me
live with your fear embrace it later
[Laughter]
you have a marker i bet you could do
something more messed up
draw a second dick
is it going to read actual size
you know front wedgy thing
you know what it's like oh i've
experienced multiple
back wedgies and they're no picnic
either
okay let's not make this thing
season four oh season four you just had
a meat cute
she's out me cute i knew you'd be back
oh really yeah i think we all did yeah
here catch i'm going to paralyze you now
look what i learned in japan show me
cast the rod
nice block cast the rod
so the fishing trip was karate training
after all more of a
happy coincidence you're a little
manipulator aren't you dad
he's going to get traumatic flashbacks
have chosen that
yo you've been here before love is gear
things are different he's not oh i
thought he wasn't talking to anybody
say we need a roof four walls
screw that you don't need a dojo
to be a dojo is that understood
nice not bad i started cobra kite with
one nerd this is a step
up we need a name
that commands respect is that the title
of the episode
there's only one animal i can kill a
snake
a mongoose a real animal bird
a lion a gun
gun the eagle fang karate
oh jesus eagles don't have thanks
[Laughter]
eagle fan karate
no anyone else feeling a little snug
do some more sit-ups all right
you still got it i don't know about this
all right everybody looks like our class
just got a little bigger make room is
this a mislead
yes
yeah it is damn it oh
son of a [ __ ]
you're crazy if you think i'm ever
teaming up with you again i care about
my students
um and they wouldn't make the mistake of
showing mercy and ending up in a coma
oh [ __ ] it's not gonna be another chance
good good yeah you are gonna regret it
[Music]
oh what a good show i know
johnny's dojo versus increases dojo
yes i love this what a good
show
[Music]
this show is so much about legacy and
they know how to just
keep that theme so strong yeah
seriously man that's so impressive
so impressive my co-star for my cat from
hell is here oh
god you're so hellish you should join
cobra kai
[Laughter]
the show just keeps getting better and
better everything's been ramping up
ramping up wrapping up getting more
intense and this one has some
big turn of events but at the same time
it kind of slowed it down a little bit
that just has some good character
lessons and some good
you know just drama but then you could
feel that this point
is gonna really ramp it up now which is
kind of interesting
slow it down but let's plant some seeds
and now we're going to get crazy but
there are some so like
no need to get too bogged down in
theories and all that like i've been
talking about every episode that each
episode presents itself with a specific
theme
and this one seemed to be so much about
overcoming fear or you could say
obstaculous perfect
obstacles yep got that and it means are
perfect obstacles
in spanish i thought it might have meant
eagle fang fighters
it was very close they're similar
translations
but overcoming obstacles and not just
physical obstacles but obstacles within
ourselves that seem to have kind of this
double meaning
throughout you know what i mean kind of
like with sam having her physical scars
but there's the emotional scars within
yeah and then for the fishing and the
and the bo staffs
i just want to acknowledge you know i
make a lot of jokes but every once in a
while i
say something so intellectually deep
that i blow myself away
i'm blown away just sitting next to you
i know attention
release i'm really ready to say anything
because i know it's just not going to be
as eloquent or as elegant as you are but
yeah with them overcoming obstacles and
and every
which way i mean the big heart of it had
i mean there's a lot of heart actually i
think
prevailing throughout this whole episode
with sam
and um daniel like i was saying towards
the end of the reaction now so much of
this deals with legacy
and honoring that it's so cool how this
series
just keeps reminding me that this could
have not been bogged down with legacy
but bogged down by nostalgia
they know how to use nostalgic moments
and make that feel integral to the
legacy just like going back
to the west valley tournament um gym
having that flashback from karate kid
about dealing with fear and how you're
just watching that footage you know it's
getting me a little misty odd but then
showing how
even that legacy again that time from
the 80s is so prevalent to what sam's
going through now
and i remember like well named names but
i was like 17 years old
17 or 18. i was at a party with friends
and a big fight was bound to break out
from my friends having issues with other
people
and a big fight broke out and i
remembered i kind of i had something
kind of similar with sam like i did 10
years of martial arts
and it had been a while since i had done
martial arts like like a few years
at that point like as i did it from like
four to 14. i remember
freezing when the fight broke out like i
just froze i couldn't move
it was kind of weird i didn't know what
the hell was happening i eventually took
a guy i threw him in a pool
who came in because i saw my friend was
getting punched so i was like i should
probably do something
snapped out but i didn't like throw any
fists i like grabbed a gun i just threw
my pool
and uh my point with that though is
having that feeling that's kind of
that tended to be my dreams and
nightmares is i'm being attacked and i
can't move
that's that says something about me
psychologically
but that was for the longest time that
would be my most
reoccurring thing with my nightmares and
dreams i'm in some situation
and i just can't move and i'm being
attacked i'm about to be killed i know
it sounds like dark deep and heavy but
i'm bringing this up because i've
probably seen like a handful of comments
really rip on sam
while i've not been a high school girl
in this scenario
i really think they've done a much
better job at fleshing her out this
season and i think this is very human
what she's going through so i really
like the writing of what they've been
doing with her character
oh yeah i mean those scenes between her
and danny and just the progression
of that conversation because it you know
carried through several scenes as she
starts to open up like
i was getting misty during those scenes
and yeah i was really feeling the
emotion i feel like pervert
that's right man i was so moist during
those scenes oh you pervert that's right
man
uh in fact i'm just gonna go to the
bathroom right now and
i'm sorry i got sincere so i needed to
mix it yeah yeah i gotta know i i feel
you don't don't be too vulnerable for
too long
but yeah like this episode struck me as
as
maybe being like a sort of dramatic
centerpiece of sorts for the season
because like there have been a lot of
touching and dramatic moments but this
episode seemed like every plot line
was going there in some degree yeah yeah
and i mean i really love starting the
episode like it feels like it gets
more grave as it goes but i really loved
the early parts of the episode watching
miguel and johnny
like really getting him back up on his
feet and moving and stuff
like it feels like one of those words
like okay let's start with the the t is
the theme of trauma
then let's do something light get our
sort of wins
out of the way and then we'll go into
the dramatic and set up the stakes for
the last leg of the season
and it was nice seeing like it was nice
seeing uh miguel back at school
this is like a clear more defined
establishment of his changing character
because we
saw him descending throughout cobra kai
becoming more of a bully you see that
he's
he's more himself of what we saw in the
beginning stages of first season but now
he's tough he's strong he's going to
stand up for himself but he has no
interest in being a bully
at all i love that i love seeing that i
mean he was never like on the level of
hawk or something
no but there was a time where he was
kind of lost yeah he was kind of a dick
yeah
and so i like seeing where he's at here
seeing him go to school and how he's
trying to see that light in them but
they did tease that oh yeah hawk and
miguel will go toe-to-toe
they have to they have to yeah yeah and
it's these are yeah no no it is
whatever you were gonna say um but yeah
and
and the way they've been playing with
hawk like i am
still waiting to see how that turns out
but more so than the previous
see especially more so than like season
two i am becoming engrossed by whatever
his internal conflict is because it
seems quite clear
people get through to a part of him and
i love that moment where johnny steps up
to him and he's like you were as soft as
they come when i first met you and i
made you what you are
or at least i was a huge contributor to
it you know i'm really rooting for this
season to do something really
interesting with
the remaining cobras because too you've
got this also dynamic with kyler being
back and he's
totally victimizing dimitri on his own
time but he also has this sort of
fear of hawk now because of that display
from the last episode so i can see
the seeds in a less obvious way for
maybe a rift to start happening within
cobra kai or something you know well
there seems to be
the you even see it with tori to a
certain extent
some seeds of doubt they're going to
leave go to johnny's and then cobra kell
be
led by that asian guy yes
finally after three seasons yeah he's
got a main asian character
in a karate show yeah he's a complete
dick
the dimitri stuff was wow
that what's her name again oh my god
what is her name oh no
blonde meaning who god becomes mean i
think it is she signs this
cast yeah and so yeah i think it's
yasmine you called her yeah she loves
his [ __ ]
this season is a little more adult than
i would have expected i mean
it's it's grow it's growing you're
growing
as the show grows the audience also
grows so it gets more mature gets more
erect
i love how there's like this push and
pull reward for
um dimitri you know he's not solely
bullied there are times where he is bull
like he's got a cast in his arm but that
is such a rewarding and awesome moment
because you know it's high school
you know her status his status versus
hers
and that you're just like that will do
wonders for him yeah yeah
that is great for him you know that's
that's one of the few happy byproducts
of being bullied is every now and again
someone's like hey hey don't don't don't
pay me but then having the the dynamic
of
them possibly a romantic inkling
is really cool i i root for the
underdogs all the time i was here for
the underdog well yeah and i mean
it is kind of tropey and this sort of
like ah he's
clearly sort of of the nerd set of the
school and she
up until you know she had the whole
front wedgie thing is you know like
at the top of the elite of the popular
sphere but at the same time yeah
again just the way they've packed the
nuances on you know i could actually
maybe see it happening you know because
they've both been humanized to each
other
so i'm excited for the new school the
park
all good stuff and also it's cool when
it's like when the show's like you but
he he is a father and he's got to be a
father to sam
um and he doesn't evidently give two
shits about his son
he was in the one episode
i forgot he had his son everything's
fine
like the show seems to have no
acknowledgement everything's
fine how old is he now like 12.
this is this rare show i have no
criticisms for and anything that seems
just kind of silly or off i
i'm just more charmed by it this might
be a perfect series yeah because even
the things that are off are charmingly
off
yeah it's just like oh yeah meme sun is
bad like that
it's just funny yeah he just showed us
what happens kid all day yeah who
watches him where is he
so much about her being in high
schoolership and she's in high school
does he go to the stadium
comment below if you know season four is
gonna be huge he's gonna be like but
what happened with the dealership and
the snakes
they're fine i guess yeah we need to
figure we need to solve it to take a day
off
still got three more episodes to watch i
love this show
thank you guys for watching subscribe
click that notification bell do you that
you like high school
are you going to high school i don't
know what to ask if you've already seen
the series do you have any dramas you
need to overcome
unpack them in the comments patron of
the day shout out
robert gunderson listen buddy you
recently pledged
to our patreon you're qualified for a
patron of the day shout out
i'm sorry i haven't properly replied to
you yet it's been like
10 to 12 hours a day in front of a
computer having to do all this editing
and stuff
i'm not saying that's any excuse to not
have a thorough conversation with you
but i wanted to say
damn it i have to shout out a man named
robert gunderson
in a cobra kai video because let's face
it
if there was a new villain introduced
and they said
robert gunderson is the name of that
villain i'd be like damn
that cobra kai has amazing writing
that's right that is a perfect name for
a cobra kai villain yeah man
so robert stay badass dude yeah don't be
a [ __ ] tune up those guns
gunderson thanks for being part of our
patreon page
you've joined for the right tier that's
badass man
gundersen gundersen that's like the
light it's just the light
yeah that's the light gunderson oh god
gunderson what were you thinking turning
your badge gundress into
your damn job sarge damn it we have no
time gunderson your methods may be
unorthodox get the job